the wikipedia defines biology as
a branch of science that studies living
organisms
and several prominent sites define
biology as
the study of life
what is interesting is that no one
has been able to define the words life
and living
so
what is it that biologists
study more fundamental yet
is science about
studying
[Music]
if we look up the word science in
dictionaries and encyclopedias
we find the word study almost everywhere
the collins dictionary defines science
as the study of nature and behavior of
natural things
and the wikipedia tells us that
natural science is the study of the
physical world
social science is the study of human
behavior and functioning of societies
the oxford dictionary in turn defines
study as
the devotion of time and attention to
gaining knowledge of an academic subject
especially by means of books and the
collins dictionary says something
similar
to apply the mind to the learning
especially by reading
to study all night
what have you studied all night and
didn't understand anything
what if you studied your book all week
and got a zero on the test
do you qualify as a scientist
is studying just memorizing
regurgitating
is science like poetry
reciting mantras you repeat while
counting beads on your rosary
so the question you should ask is
whether science is learning by rote
which happens to be the way we learn in
school
which only perpetuates the status quo
and that might explain why contemporary
so-called scientists have no answers to
questions such as what is the underlying
mechanism of gravity
what causes a magnet to attract another
one
food for thought
[Music]